yeah hello welcome to a new video and
yeah this video is meant as a sort of
appetizer for the upcoming match between
Levon Aronian and vladimir kramnik
starting tomorrow tomorrow means april
twenty year first on the the planar
Switzerland a six-game match and it's a
friendly match it's not for some some
title or specific specific price or
something it's a training match if you
will um yeah one thing on I'd like to
also dresses yet the first game on play
tomorrow on april twenty first um will
also be yeah broadcast in a yeah on a
twitch channel um and there will be a
life comentarii done by a friend of mine
brandon from from the united states and
by me um we'll start a couple of minutes
before the game starts so slightly
before on 3 p.m. european time which
would be 9 a.m. eastern standard time
i'll also post the address of the twitch
channel in the video description here on
youtube its twitch.tv / chess explained
just explained without an ease though so
explain and naughty explained so to say
but just use the link that would be
provided in the in the text um alright
um yeah the appetizer here in this video
is it's a game that I am that I chose to
present between the two players I was
going through the game center with was
thinking what what kind of game I should
present because they played many
in games of course I was in general
rather surprised that the overall score
is very heavily in chrome Knicks favor I
was expecting more than of an even
result because the players are are
pretty much even in strength but chrome
nick has a pretty pretty decent plus
gone in classical time control games
actually aronian only managed to win one
game Kramnik I think won three or four
and the game that the ronnian one was
from a worse position but he's very good
at that need to mention that erroneous
big fighter in bad positions and often
even managers a complete turnaround and
even wins and so at the end I selected
the game witches yeah actually not of
the highest quality in pure chance terms
but it was a dramatic game and also just
the rapid game the game starting
tomorrow will be classical time control
so up to let's say seven hours total
plane time at this rapid game that are
selected from the amber tournament in
2010 was just 30 minute game or 25
minutes I didn't look it up so rapid
time control but the game was very tense
and very dramatic so interesting to
follow at least I know that I am I
watched this game really live at it was
being played and I know that people were
really yeah really fascinated because it
was such a tough battle okay um let's
start I'm Aronian playing wide time and
he plays deform um this is his main
movie also from time to time place see
493 never go see form but he plays all
the closed openings um Kramnik here opts
forums or Indian which are often does of
course and now Aronian plays III the
Rubenstein system which is I think as
main weapon against the nums Oh castles
Bishop d3 just normal development now
black goes c5 putting a foothold in the
center and now Knight f3 so just the
classical way of developing often people
are somewhat put off by the bishop and
see one here in the Rubenstein system
because it looks rather passive but this
III setup guarantee is wider quick
development of the King side and a quick
cancelling and very often then the
bishop gets into play later because
white gets to move his I porn at some
point or black maybe exchange a sonde
form for instance a main line here could
could be a cd4 8045 castles take stakes
and the bishop is no problem anymore
very often the center opens up in in
some way because there are lots of lines
the names o has heaps of theory chronic
now plays b6 which is um yeah less
popular move of course on a playable
move but it's not not seen so often and
Aronian of course could just castle here
and most likely transpose into some
other line for instance castles and
Bishop d7 let's say on castles Bishop e7
is a well-known position but in this
specific position white has a chance to
play d 5 which he does of course on this
changes dramatically the position to a
sort of benoni structure black now
captures and white recaptures the first
question is what if black takes on d5 he
plays h6 but let's check briefly what
what happens if he takes yeah then why
it has some very common tactic here
taking on h7 King takes Queen takes and
why it has
as a very nice position a eight is just
hanging and if black gum develop this
night there are things like this
possible and it looks very much like a
Greek gift sacrifice but white didn't
even sacrifice anything here but so
black cannot really take on d5 but this
explains has move h6 this now threatens
night XD five as nothing that what can
take on age seven so white goes for you
for here and canvas this pawn on d5 and
yeah this now leads to very interesting
complications as chrome Nick chooses a
very sharp pro sham he just captures
only form trying to use the fact that
white king is not cancelled yet so white
recaptures and now takes him Andrew
create and now we see that white hasn't
cancelled yet and he has no way to
preserve his bishop on d3 I on your form
he cannot move it and well there's no
good way to to keep it so he goes night
to d2 which forces black to play f5 to
really get the bishop now castles f take
C 4 and C form and now we see an
interesting transformation of the
position black is upon opinion but the
main point here will be dead white will
get a very strong bishop won't be too we
can do the the next move Perry a d6 is
very logical to get the c8 bishop in the
player now white goes Bishop b2 so white
has a huge bishop on b2 which points to
the g7 square which easily can become a
weakness in black skim over all blacks
Kings position could be somewhat shaky
so white has some quite good
compensation here for the palm
my first instinct my personal first
instinct would be to prefer why it but
this position is may be about equal so
let's see how it continues kramnik goes
for Queen g5 very aggressive approach
very also very very playable and now I'm
very direct move by aronian f3 auto
strong move I think slow moves don't
really help him um the idea is let go
some bishop age 3 now let's show some
ideas here if black would capture on f3
while can recapture with the Queen and
this very much speeds up on the
development black now needs to do
something about the Queen f7 check
threat here very annoying thread and
let's say he goes Queen III then y term
can just capture and still his
development advantage is very serious
even though let's say a line like this
here black noise no a lot much choice
here needs to capture now white
threatens rookie 7 and 94 capturing the
636 point is quite weak and cannot
easily be defended so why it has very
nice compensation at this position even
a thing good for white so its various
dangerous to take on f3 an alternative
would be III just advancing the pawn it
looks very strong at first side as black
is threatening to to playy to also but
right has of course an ID for gaining a
tempo in the Queen and then for instance
Queen g6 rookie one and it's difficult
for black now to keep the pawn let's say
Bishop f5 rook takes and if black now
tries to grab this pawn this rook to e3
and on
seven it's just end of game white
crashes through and yeah wins me through
material and made us not far away also
so black cannot keep this pawn with III
it was it wasn't alternative though as
some in this position of course black
doesn't need to capture can develop here
97 okay but Kramnik played bishop 83
this is the sharpest Queenie to needs to
cover g2 not much choice and now III
this was crammed Nick's idea night here
and Queen g6 yeah now strong move by
white and one that is very useful to
remember um the idea is useful to
remember of course this concrete
position you won't get on the bottom
most likely but the idea is very very
useful and this is a forum this is just
just a strong move the idea is to go
rook a3 and capture with the rukon III
so it makes optimal use of this rook
trying to capture on you three and two
moves which would greatly increase
White's activity any other route would
be just slower note that white has
problems he can never capture only 30
with the Queen as it is made on g2 so he
cannot really trying to get this pawn in
another way and this justice a very good
activation of the pieces makes really am
yeah makes good use of all our pieces
that white white hassium 97 very logical
to get this into the game and now rookie
three as mentioned yeah no actually I'm
chrome nakum commits a mistake here he
plays 95 and this son well someone some
normal move would have been okay for
black um I think there was was some
choice what would black n do but I
didn't I didn't look at this I was just
saw that this was was the problem
um but Aronian doesn't doesn't use this
opportunity it wasn't so easy to see
also you played King edge 1 which is a
very natural looking move get out of
this G file this annoying pin of the
Queen on g6 but he had a chance he could
take on d6 and this is quite strong as
quintet Queen 66 rook takes c3 put the
night into a nasty pin and white will
get the piece back black cannot move his
night as some as this thing here only
aid this rook is just hanging so white
will get the piece back on e5 with a
nice advantage but he didn't he didn't
see that please take in mind keep in
mind that it's a rapid game so this game
contains quite quite a number of
mistakes that the players wouldn't make
in a long time control game but it will
get very very dramatic now King edge one
and now Kramnik really really strikes
here he captures on c4 which is really
really a blow white cannot take on c4 of
course because of g2 mate Quincy to mate
and this move also simultaneously
attacks rook a 3 the bishop on b2 and
cover the pawn so it does lots of lots
of positive things here of course but
one point is what happens if white
captures the bishop this was hanging now
and ronnian also he took the bishop and
now Kramnik strikes the next blow with
rook takes e4 so quite out of the blue
black got some attack going here but the
amazing thing is that also this whole
operation opened up the gphone which
gives white strong counter play on g7 so
it's not the kind of
words just black all the way white will
get counter plane let's first check what
happens of course if why take the rook
first which is a mistake really but
difficult to seem like just recaptures
and then white will I think interpose
here with the Queen if he goes to g1 the
only other sensible move black can just
capture the rook and play something like
rook e8 and this is a very good position
for black keys got this absolutely
massive porn only three which greatly
hinders White's position you cannot
really move the Queen because of e2 and
black of course has got three pawns form
for the piece already and d5 a 4 h3 the
pawns of wider basically all week so
black ism it's very much better here so
let's say Queen g2 black can play easy
to gain the tempo here rookie one the
only move other otherwise black book
remote also take note that this is
direct checkmate so why cannot take the
Queen so rookie one needs to block the
pawn I'll stop the porn and now black
gum has a simple option to capture and
take on b2 and the nice thing here is
rookie 2nite c4 with the tempo so wyd
needs to move the rook first and then 95
and this is the key here that the night
reaches the the perfect square on e5
only five it just blocks the e-file so
white cannot enter rookie seven he also
will never play group f7 because the
night covers the square and yeah Black
has some extra points for this exchange
and has basically all the winning
chances here White has possibilities to
fight of course it's not not entirely
lost maybe directly but black is
certainly better here so aronian was
right not to go for this on Rupe takes
e4 I didn't capture as we analyzed but
he played Rock g1 and this immediately
gets to the g7 porn and initiates
counterplay let goes Queen a try very
logical to build up a pin here the porn
can never take the rook here because the
queen e 2 is hanging so somehow black's
pieces defend each other technically no
white X on g7 king of 8 of course you
cannot go to h eight right into the
discovery so Luke f8 and now rogue age 7
and this is really a crazy position
white um threatens of course rook h8 and
also has got ideas of getting the Queen
into the battle like Queen g2 Queen g2g
7 and made us sneer so white has some
strong counter plane and now Kramnik
commits a mistake he plays Knight xb2 of
course this is super difficult to play
it it's just hella in a red and rapid
game so mistakes are natural here um
what he could could do is sound he could
play a rook e8 a 28 for instance this
was the possibility therefore adversus
move recovering base the rook so it's
not hanging on aid and possible
continuation would be Queen g2 here
threatening on g7 which black and block
with Queen g5 that the only move really
and now for instance takes here takes
takes and who takes the form just a
fascinating position black as a rock
down but your threatens
to promote his pawn and what can do i do
let's say protects the bishop on b2
takes and white now recaptures the pawn
is just going through so wyd needs to
get some counter play rook takes a 7 to
rook check check King e7 and this is
some I didn't continue this line
actually this is funny I think this this
is a perpetual I think let's just check
with clear that I'm not not talking some
some nonsense yeah it's a perpetual okay
oops yeah I prepared some some lines
before the video of course but somehow I
didn't paint an evaluation here in the
text so this is a perpetual I'm very
difficult to see of course it's easily
measurable that on Queen g2e didn't
calculate this line so far of course
it's capable capable of doing that but
in a limited time also black could take
on a three-year was also possible rook
check King f7 ruge aid and now just
returned to e7 because after Bishop
takes Queen e5 black has got strong
counter play again Queen a1 is
threatened and now Queen c2 which
secures the draw for white with Queen h7
to come this also ends in a perpetual so
a very very sharp and difficult lines
also this move here night XP to right
after that also Aronian makes a mistake
very understandable mistake though you
could play Queen g-tube which is a
really a super difficult
to find threatening Queen g7 now and
black needs to to interpose align to a
line like let's say rookie seven rookie
seven rookie takes King takes g7 King
here and rookie three it's even winning
for white his attacker will crash
through here so Quincy five and then
white can capture and white is close to
close to two winning in this position
and some here III is hanging and also
this rook h8 is threatened the
relatively best line is something like
this and why it has very good winning
chances here you should win actually but
Queen g2 was difficult Iranian captured
only three which makes sense also for
human player of course I I looked at
this game with the help of the computer
to get some good technical checks going
and it's very very difficult to play
this over the bot exactly expected
especially considering the low time that
they most likely had so black captures
and now King g8 this actually is the
only move as rook edge eight was a heavy
thread something like this why just get
the look at the end so this is king g8
the only move now white captures Queen a
five-wicket drawn to the sir quite
logical going for root G 4f form so
black gets the night back in order to
cover f4 here
so this position now is winning for
black but it's difficult really
difficult because let's let's continue
here rookie form he grabbed the pawn
which is not its which is okay rookie
seven check and now I'm the black
commits the decisive not at his house
decides a mistake but he spoils his
advantage he absolutely needed to go to
f6 and this is winning but this is of
course a very tough decision to to
actually pull the king yeah heads out
the same and not drop it back to have
eight the crazy is say a thing is that
here white simply doesn't have enough to
to get could get decent play against the
king at sec row gauge seven rook g8
between e7 King g6 and somehow there's
no no real continuation what doesn't
even have a decent check here the Queen
D 5 covers f7 and so this is not
completely easy to play for for black
but it should be you should be winning
considering low time of course okay but
here you went to evade and it's not
immediately obvious why there should be
a mistake but it will be soon rook h7
here actually a black had a chance
though to to get a big advantage Wilson
I deaf too but who plays that it's just
a computer move and then rook e8
activating the rook like is quite
clearly better here but of course cannot
expect this move to be played he just
played King g8 attacking the rook rook
c7 and now I guess he noticed the
problems that that are in this position
as why threatens the nasty
Queen g1 check so if black goes let's
say rook f8 or something like this
attacking f3 white has the funny
backward move Queen g1 these are always
hard to always easy to miss and this is
just made on g7 King moves and Queen g7
checkmate and maybe here overlooked this
idea and black really has no moose yeah
this Queen g1 is is just terrible you
could go here but this is Queen g5 and
this is quite similar made on g7 or e7
to come black really has no move other
than this desperado check here to get
the queen of the e-file here and now
king of eight this just prevents
immediate disaster Queenie three white
threatens again Queenie seven but now
black has a series of checks here and
white of course why Troy still tries to
win he could easily drop the King back
and it's a draw what he tries to the
utmost here to win and it wins is asking
to H form and yeah black still needs to
give checks he doesn't have much else so
check here and Queen g5 and out of this
insanely complicated to a middle game we
now arrived at at the absolutely unusual
end game where black has got
disconnected passed pawn C 4 C 5 of 5
and d6 and white has the activity the
rook on the seventh King on f8 is
passive and white has the effort age
pawns the F poor mostly to to use so
let's just see em how it continued I
think this is fairly logical d5 f4d for
so both players push their pawns and our
rookie aid trying to finally use rook
and play rookie 72 to block the
seventh-ranked so King f6 is very
logical d3 ruge f7 King g8 Luke g7 check
king age 8 so both players really go for
the win here black could have played
King ever the King evade also Rock d7c
form so doesn't it look good for black
lips at first sight the connected passes
here but in fact the position is still
equal amazingly Kingair 7 rook c8 and
now very interesting point again now
aronian actually while trying to win
commits a mistake he plays f6 very
natural move of course pushing the pawn
um I have to have six actually Cromley
could have gotten winning chances but
white could have drawn here with King g6
and it's this absolutely amazing line
king jew six black gum pushes c3 trying
to promote and now rook h7 check in King
g8 only move f6 and now white yeah
threatens f7 rue gage aid so black plays
rook c6 and pins on this pawn and now
the really amazing line rook takes a
seven threatening rook aid check made on
my next move so blank goes for this
desperado sacrifice IAM and place d2 and
it looks like these pawns are
unstoppable rook t8 c2 and now
absolutely crazy rook da check King edge
seven route d7
brooke age six King edge six of course
he goes back it's it's perpetual check
so root page six King age 65 keep a
single because Ruby aid may be here is
the key move now and now amazingly rook
h8 checkmate threatened and black cannot
escape really he can go back and it's a
draw with rock d 7 but you cannot go to
h5 as this is a funny checkmate where
this the silly hit double porn on 83 is
playing the key role in taking the
square on g4 and absolutely a great line
it's right right out of office study I
guess just just just great so King g6
would have led to to this draw if they
would have found all this but it's it's
possible it's possible f6 very natural
move by Aronian of course whites next
move will be f6 and King g6e just
somehow switched the moves but now I'm
cromley could have gone King edge 7k six
King h6 and black and try to to win even
with his pawns but he committed a
mistake I guess under huge time pressure
and played c3 and now rube deformed this
is this is an issue rook h4 checkmate is
the the heavy threat here black only can
go here King g6 this again threatens
checkmate on d aid so he has to has to
drop back rookie em check King g8 and
it's it's over
yeah and black resigned I guess it was
very heavy time pressure at the end he
would have resigned earlier I guess so
at the end I think very low clock times
somebody decided this game but I think I
really like this game as it was a great
battle and has very nice lines up to the
very end and both players really fought
super hard for for win here so we I
let's um let's hope that this upcoming
match which starts tomorrow will also
give us some nice fighting chest they
have the quite interesting rule set up
in the contract that if a game is a draw
I think under three hours playing time
arm maybe also below 40 moves then they
will play an additional rapid game on
this day so in case for whatever reason
they they play quick draw because they
were whatever both got their preparation
and it's just just the draw then we will
at least get to see some some nice rapid
action and as we just saw them quite
good at rapping and producing
interesting fighting games yeah make
sure if you have the time to to tune in
tomorrow to this broadcast um I think
we'll do some enjoyable and also maybe
yes I'm a joya below comentarii and hope
to catch you on twitchtv tomorrow you
will also of course be able to chat and
make suggestions so I think this might
be more more interesting even then
watching some other comentarii feed
where you cannot really participate we
will also we will look at lines that you
you might suggest or answer questions so
yeah I hope to see em many of you in the
broadcast tomorrow yeah thanks for
watching and I guess talk to you
tomorrow